hello everyone
and welcome to today's live broadcast
investigation
of nk cell-driven tumor immunity using
novel image cytometry detection method
i'm christy jewell of labyrinths and
i'll be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
brought to you by labyrinths
and sponsored by nexolum bioscience for
more information on our sponsor
click on the sponsor logo on the left
side of your screen or visit nexalon.com
now let's get started i would like to
remind everyone that this event is
interactive
and we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box
and click send also please notice you
can share this webinar on your personal
social media
just click on the social sharing tab to
let your friends and colleagues know
about today's live event now if you have
any trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation
click on the support tab found at the
top right of your presentation window
or you can use that ask a question box
and let us know you're experiencing a
problem
we have two presenters for you today
speaking first
is dr lucas ferrari d'andrade assistant
professor
precision immunology institute icann in
school of medicine at mount sinai
following dr ferrari d'andradi is dr leo
chan
technology research and development
manager advanced technology research and
development and collaboration at mexico
bioscience for complete biographies on
our speakers
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your screen
welcome dr ferrari dandrotti and dr chan
you may now begin
your presentations
okay thank you christina so uh this is
lucas
so uh what i will present today is the
work that i did during my postdoc
so i i recently joined the icons of
medicine at mount sinai
this is why i use their logon here but
most of the work was done
during my postdoc at the dana fiber and
let me
to introduce you to natural killer cells
so these
natural killer cells are simply any k
cells they are
innate immune cells uh that have the
capability to recognize
and kill tumor cells and they also
produce cytokines and chemokines that
activate
the anti-tumor immunity so they are a
very important component of the
anti-tumor immunity
and uh and the there is a
very scientifically interesting
mechanism by which any k cells recognize
tumor cells so uh here in this slide we
have a tumor cells uh
expressing mick a and mick b so mk and
mkb
are m8c1 like molecules however
they do not present antigens they do not
associate with the beta 2m
and are not ubiquitously expressed like
mhc class 1 molecules
so mca and mkb they are really distinct
they are only expressed by cells that
are under some sort of cellulite stress
such as stress caused by dna damage
unfolded the proteins hypoxia
so in other words the expression of mk
and mkb
flags cells that are under some sort of
cellulite stress
and these pathways are upregulated by
tumor cells and therefore
uh this protein uh is actually
upregulated by tumor cells but not by
healthy cells
and any case cells have a receptor for
mickey and mkb which is called nkg2d
so nkg2d is an activating receptor
that recognizes the mechanic kb
molecules and this receptor is present
only in
k cells an ekg2d promotes
the cytotoxicity by nk cells so upon
recognition
of mechanical b by this receptor nk
cells release
enzymes and perform that kill tumor
cells
and they also produce and secrete
interferon gamma which activates the
antitumor immunity
however uh mickey and mike b are
proteolytically cleaved
so uh proteolytic cleavage is a pos
translational modification
uh in by which cells release the entire
extracellular domain of surface proteins
so this is the case for mechanical which
you see in this slide here
so imagine that this would be the
surface of a tumor cells
it is known that erp5 a disulfide
isomerase
removes diesel find bond on the
on this bottom domain of the mk and uh
this allows an interaction with
proteases such as atom17
which cleaves the stock of the protein
released the entire extracellular domain
including the nkg2d binding sites and as
a consequence of this
the nkg receptor is unable to recognize
the tumor cells because
the ligand mckay is simply shed by the
tumor cells
and this this protein is released by
tumors and it is found
uh in the circulation of of of patients
with cancer
so here we have uh analyze analysis of
survival of melanoma patients treated
with iep limo map
and these authors compare it uh the
levels of
solubomic a uh between uh patients who
will
live it longer and patients who live
shorter and what they saw is that
the high levels of soluble mccain the
syrup is associated with
uh shorter overall survival so this
suggests that
mccain mcbee shedding is a therapeutic
target
so we wanted to to block this process to
prevent the cleavage of mick
a so see here on the left side the
mickey uh and also it's the same thing
for mkb
they are two different proteins but they
have a almost 90 percent of an amino
acid identity
so here we illustrate mickey interacting
with nkg2d
and uh what you can uh appreciate is
that the nkg to the receptor recognizes
the alpha one and alpha two domains of
this molecule
which is on the top are far from the
from the cell membrane
on the other hand the alpha 3 domain
serves
kind of as a column that supports the
alpha 1 and 2 domains
and the alpha 3 domain is also where uh
the erp5
cuts the disulfide bond so therefore we
hypothesized
that we could generate antibodies
against the alpha 3 domain
and these antibodies would prevent the
interaction between mka and the
proteases
therefore inhibiting the cleavage of mca
so that's what we did we produced the
recombinant of a three domain we
immunized the uh
bob semis to generate monoclonal
antibodies and uh making a long story
short
we end up with three monoclonal
antibodies against the alpha three
domain of mckay
so the monoclonal antibodies are clones
766
6f11 and 1c2 and
as you can see this eliza our antibodies
they were able to
to recognize the alpha one that's the
full length
a which consists of alpha one and three
domains
and also only the recombinant alpha
three domain so therefore our antibodies
uh they recognize the alpha three domain
of
k but then you may think well there are
monoclonal antibodies commercially
available
yes uh i know you can buy them in many
different stores
so the best described one is the clone
64
but as you can see this clone 64 which
is commercially available
it recognizes the full-length mickey but
not the alpha-3 domain
suggesting that the the commercially
available antibody recognizes the alpha
one and two domain so it's not the type
of antibody that we want
so the first thing we did uh we are now
going to characterize
these antibodies and the first thing we
did was to uh determine if
they offer three binders do not block
the nkg receptor
this is very important because we don't
want uh the indicator to d
uh to we wanted any kids to still be
able to recognize mca
even if our antibodies bounded to it and
and that's indeed the case here's a flu
cyclometer essay with a tumor cell
expressing mca
and we saw that we are able to stain
mickey using an ndk to the
fc chimera uh and if we add our
antibodies the cloning seventh
cx6 f11 c2 our antibodies did not
prevent
uh the binding of nkg2d to this cell
line
however the 6d4 antibody the
commercially available one
completely blocks the nkg2d receptor
so of to test if our antibodies inhibit
the cleavage
we did the in vitro assays in which we
culture a human melanoma cell line
uh for 24 hours in the presence of
different concentrations of our
antibodies
and then we collected the supernatants
we analyzed the soluble michael
shed into the supernatants and we also
analyze the surface mickey b molecules
by flow cytometry
so here on the left side uh we see that
this
8375 melanoma cell line produces around
600 picograms per ml of
soil of shed mccain the super natives
and if we add the isotope control
control antibody or the 64 antibody
there is no effect
on the other hand if we add our
antibodies in color
you can see that in a dose dependent
manner these antibodies
prevented the release of soluble mickey
into the supernatants
and as a consequence this these proteins
were stabilized on the surface of the
tumor cells
which you see here on the right side a
uh a phosphate of surfacing k and b so
this suggests
that when we inhibit the mca shedding
the protein is
stabilized on the cell surface so this
protein is a ligand
for the nkg2d receptor and what we
thought is uh
this type of approach would enhance the
nk cell
uh mediated the killing of the tumor
cells and this is indeed the case
uh most of the experiment we did uh
focused on the 766 clone
which is one of our antibodies because
we saw it was the most effective one
inhibiting shedding
in in other cell lines and what you see
here on the left side is a regular
chromo51 release essay
in which we uh use any case cell we call
co-training k-cells with tumor cells
and we analyze the killing of the tumor
cells by nk cells
and we saw that uh the tumor cells
escaping and cancer recognition in the
absence of the antibody
but if we add our antibody with a
humanity one heavy chain
we see a very uh substantial increase in
the percentage of killing
and i also see that these nk cells
produce interferon gamma here on the
right side against
a different different type of tumor cell
so uh we we think this
type of approach could work potentially
as a as a
immunotherapy and to test this we would
we what we did was to performing vivo
experiments
with this antibody but mice do not have
the mca or mkb
genes so we wanted to make sure that the
mouse nkg2d receptor is able to
recognize
the human mechanic b proteins so what to
test it is what we did
was a bead essay in which we tested the
binding of mouse or human naked 2d
proteins
they binding to the recombinant mca
using different polymorphic variants and
what you can appreciate
here is that human nkg2d bounded to all
of the variants that we tested
and also the mouse indicated to the
receptor boundary to the other variants
that we tested
suggesting that the mouse indicated to
the receptor is able to recognize the
human mca
and the other thing we did uh we
inserted the humanic
a or humanik bc dna into this mouse
melanoma cell line in b16 f10
and what we note said is that after
doing that the cells
proteolytically cleave be even though
these proteins are humans are from
humans and we saw that
again our antibodies were able to
stabilize uh mechanical on the surface
of the tumor cell so this also works for
mouse cell lines
uh therefore we the first two more model
we did we uh
do an intravenous inoculation of b16 f10
cells expressing
a uh this is done in immunocompetent
black six mice
and then one day later we treated the
mice with the the antibody the 766
with a mouse igg to a heavy chain and
after
14 days of tumor cells inoculation we
analyze the number of metastases in the
lungs
and as you can see here my situation
with an isotope control have around
100 meters in the lungs but the ones
treated with the 766 have a very
substantial decrease in the number of
metastases
and that these metastases in the lungs
produce
mca which is shed in the circulation of
the mice
but they were not detected in my street
of the 766 because
our antibody inhibits the mk shedding
even in vivo
but like i said mice do not have the mca
and mkb genes
and as a consequence when we inoculate
the tumor cell line expressing these
hemoproteins
uh mice develop an endogenous antibody
response against mechanical
as you can appreciate it here after 14
days we see
the generation of mouse antibodies
against mka
so these are not our antibodies this is
a polyclonal response
so we wanted to to test if our
antibodies
are able to treat uh
established metastasis and to do this we
use it
uh ighm nocautomize which do not
develop endogenous antibodies against mk
so this enables us to delay
the start of antibody treatment to day
seven
which you see here on the left side on
day seven if
we perform an analysis in a subset of
mice we see that there is already a
presence of a metastasis
uh and then we start a treatment in a
different group of mice
and uh seven days later we collect to
the samples and we saw that there was an
increase in the number of metastases
in mindset to the isotype but not the
ones treated with the 766
suggesting that our antibodies was able
to
prevent the outer growth of established
metastasis
and we compared this effect uh by
knocking out
different genes in the b16 cells such as
the beta 2m and jack one
and the reason why we did this is
because uh uh resistance to t cell
checkpoint blockade was previously
associated
with lots of functional mutations in
these genes so we wanted to know if it
is our antibody could
potentially work against the tumors
which are resistant
to uh t cell checkpoint blockade and
indeed this was the
the case our antibody worked against the
builder trim knockout and also check one
deficient cell lines
so so far what we showed here is that
the antibody inhibits
uh the proteolytic delivery of mca
because it binds to the alpha 3 domain
we saw that it
enhances any case cell cytotoxicity and
it has an
a therapeutic effect in vivo so now what
we want to know
is the mechanism of action of this
antibody so
uh the first thing we did was to deplete
different immune cell populations from
mice in the b16 metastasis model
here using wire type mice with antibody
treatment starting on day one
so what we wanted to know is is if any k
cells are required
for the antibody to work and as you can
see here
when we deplete cd8 t cells which also
expressed nkg 2d
this did not prevent the antibody from
inhibiting the metastasis
on the other hand when we deplete any k
cells with either antenna k11 or
aziology m1
we saw substantial decrease in the
increase in the number of metastases
and the antibody was ineffective and the
antibody was also ineffective
in mice which were deficient for
perforin so this suggests
that our antibody promotes the dnacaceal
mediated cytotoxicity in vivo and this
is an essential mechanism for the
inhibition of metastasis
therefore we wanted to characterize the
nk cells because uh nk cells
is a heterogeneous population of immune
cells uh but this is extremely
challenging because
uh the lung the lungs are
are full of blood so we wanted to find a
manner to differentiate
the lung infiltrating any k cells from
the blood and k cells
and to do so we just prior to the
analysis
we inoculate mice with uh intravenous
with a
apc conjugate label cd45 antibody
and then this type of injection would
is staying only the blood leukocytes
after we collected the lungs we do an
uh another stain with the same clone of
antibody but
with a different fluorophore and we
therefore we can differentiate two
different populations here
one apc high the other one psi seven
high
so the psi seven high are the lung uh
infiltrating
leukocytes and then we get out uh the t
cells get in any uh group one iocs which
are in k11 and kp46 double positive
and as you can see the lung infiltrating
one is upregulate cd69
which in vivo is a tissue residency
marker
so we isolated this nak cell seven days
after tumor cell inoculation
and therefore six days after antibody
treatment and we did a single cell
rna-seq analysis of these cells
and uh this what we see are the nakp-46
in k11 double positive cells cd3 tcr
beta double negative cells
so these are group one iocs and what we
saw is that in my situation of the
isotype
most of these cells have a gene
signature similar to ilc populations
such as this purple and blue cells here
on the other hand in my street with our
antibody most of them
had the signature associated with the
activation of any k
cells such as upper regulation of enzyme
a b
and performing suggesting that our
receptors
are activating any k cells in vivo
however uh anyone who works with any k
cells know that
any k cells express not only any kg 2d
but also the cd16fc receptor
and uh our antibody has on fc that's
recognized by
cd16 and therefore what we wanted to do
next
was to test if uh the
antibody would activate any k cells even
in the absence of cd16
so to do that we generated a mutant
version of the 766
which uh has the dana mutations these
mutations completely eliminate binding
to the cd16 fc receptor which you see
here on the right side
and then we compared our antibodies
so we have here two large experiments
one in vitro on the left
side one and vivo on the right side so
the in future experiments is a naked
cell mediated the killing assay
in which we used the dana mutant 766 and
we compared
on saucer we didn't we just used a denim
mutant uh with or without any kg to
de-blockade
what we saw is that the denim mutant
antibody increases the indication of
data the killing of the melanoma cell
line
but if we block the nkg receptor this
effect is lost
and on the right side is the b16
metastasis model
in which we did the same thing and we
saw that the dynamic antibody is able to
inhibit
the outer growth of metastasis and this
effect is lost
if we block the nkg to d receptor so
what
this suggests is that the inhibition of
a shedding
restores the energy to the recognition
of tumor cells by any k cells
and then next we compared the data
mutant antibody with
the humanity g1 antibody which is the
one that
also engages the fc receptor and here is
again a carbon 51 release
essay in which we compare these two
antibodies and again you see that the
dynamic antibody increases cytotoxicity
uh but the human igg1 which also
triggers adcc has a much stronger effect
uh suggesting that although the nhd
receptor is sufficient
to to increase in kcl cytotoxicity
uh the binding 2fc receptor
is beneficial because it increases even
further
we also wanted to test this in vivo
but we we did a different approach
so we actually reconstituted regulators
which are
deficient of any k cells we
reconstituted them with a mouse and key
cells from different
mouse strains such as wire type mice are
mice which
are knockout for the fc uh receptor gene
or mice which are knockout for the neck
h2d receptor these are the ko rk1 alkal
mice
and also we have a double knockout mice
so what you can appreciate from this
figure is
in type mice sorry in regular game of
semi is reconstituted with wire type and
k
cells we see an inhibition of metastasis
but not
uh and if the mice do not have any k
cells the antibody does not work
on the other hand my sonar count either
for the fc receptor or the nkg2d
we see uh the antibodies two works but
the effect is more variable
on the other hand in mice without
both receptors with nk cells without
both receptors the antibodies
ineffective
so what this is suggesting is our
antibody causes a dual
engagement of the nk3d and fc receptors
in k
cells and this potently promotes dna
cell
mediated the killing of tumor cells
so in this tumor model uh we the b16
metastasis model
we it is something uh relatively
artificial because
the tumor cells were transduced by an
antivirus to express humanik a
but in human cancer the expression of
mckay and mkb is triggered by
a malignant transformation so we wanted
to make sure that our antibody works
against uh
human tumor cells and with the human
naked cells in vivo
but this is extremely challenging
because uh human naked cells don't
survive long
in uh in any sg mice unless we provide
io2
so what the way we did we inoculated the
human k
cells from healthy donors into ns2 mice
and then we treated the mice with uh io2
in order to support in case of survival
and one day later we inoculated a human
melanoma cell line a2058
and one day later we treated the mice
with our antibodies so we analyzed the
metastasis in the lungs uh one month
after tumor cell inoculation
and what you can see here on the graph
is that the antibody
only works if any mice were
reconstituted with any k cells
so this is the number of metastases in
the lungs you can appreciate that there
was a substantial decrease
in the number of metastases in the lungs
only in the presence of any k cells
we acknowledge that the effect is not
very strong but this is because uh it is
extremely challenging to work with
humanik cells in vivo
uh we also noted that the 858 melanoma
cell line is highly metastatic
and it generated not only long
metastasis but also metastasis in the
liver
and we were actually really surprised to
see that
the 766 antibody inhibited the mentalism
in the liver
in the presence but also in the absence
of any k cells
so we were intrigued by that how come
the antibodies would inhibit metas in
the legal
liver without any k cells so we
note said that uh everybody knows that
the liver is
uh full of of macrophages like copper
cells
and they express fc receptors as you can
see in this flow cytometry of the
macrophage from the liver of nsg mice
and if we depleted these macrophages
using liposomal chlorinate
in the absence of any k cells the
antibodies ineffective
those suggesting that our antibodies not
only uh
promoted any k-cell juveniling immunity
but also this type of immunity triggered
by myeloid cells
and finally we did an analysis of
survival in mice were constituted within
a key cells and we saw
the antibody prolonged the survival we
think that if
we improve this type of model by pro
by with another mouse strength has a
long uh
in which any case i've survived longer
we think this survival could be much
improved
so and then the other thing we wanted to
know is so there are
other types of treatments that are known
to upregulate
the expression of mickey and mickey b
and one of them is the panobinostat
and it's back inhibitor that is fda
approved for multiple myeloma
and there are also multiple clinical
trials testing penobinosis and other
types of cancer
it is known that panobinostat causes an
upper regulation of mca
and mcb genes and uh what we did
here we combined our antibody with pano
binostat
so the way we did this we on the left
side you see these
three graphics this is uh in vitro
experiments in which we kept constantly
the amount of panel binos that
oh sorry the amount of antibodies to 20
microgram per ml
but we did a dozen response curve with
panopinocete concentration and what you
you can appreciate is that penobinosides
uh combined with our antibody causes a
very substantial increase
in the amount of surface medicare on the
cell cell on the tumor cells
and this effect was also happening in
vivo
on the right side we inoculated nsg mice
with the a375 melanoma cell line
and uh uh notes that in our previous
study we used the
melanoma cell line now we are talking
about a different one the a375
and we saw that uh when we combine our
antibody with pinobinosity in vivo
we also see this very significant
increase in the mickey expression of the
on the melanoma hypothesis and we
finally tested
if our antibodies uh inhibited the
number of metastasis so
we again we did that same type of
of a human metastasis model with
nsg mice reconstituted with the human k
cells
and we administered phenomena start in
combination with 766
and what we saw is that the antibody
alone was ineffective against the a375
cell line but in combination with the
panel binos that it was able to inhibit
the metastasis this is because
penobilinos that causes an increase
on the mickey expression by the tumor
cells
so we think this could be extremely
useful in patients
not all patients not all melanoma
patients have tumors with a surface
mechanic expression
so what you see here is a panel of uh of
different patients
with a surface mca expression on the
tumor cells for example the patient cy
you see a surface mckay in this tumor
cells
and if you look on the right side this
patient cy 158
also have has a soluble mic a in
in the plasma on the other hand there
are patients without surface mickey
expressions such as the patient
cy163 here on the bottom right histogram
so this patient cy155 163 has no mickey
on the on the tumors
and there is no soluble milk in the
plasma so this patient would not
never respond to our antibody we are not
doing a clinical trial we are just
predicting how this would work
so we think that if a penobinos that
would increase the expression of mccain
this patient
it would broaden the types of
tumors that could be treated with our
antibody
so in summary what we showed here is
that
tumor cells are proteolytically cleave
which enables escape from recognition by
any k cells
on the other hand in a kg to the
receptor
uh an alpha three domain specific
antibody binds
to make a inhibits the cleavage and
enables a dual engagement of nkh2dmcd16
receptor
and as a consequence this promotes the
nk cell within the killing of the tumor
cells
so in summary i want to thank of kaivu
kofenig
from the adenofiber cancer institute and
all the several collaborators
actually uh 100 of this work was done at
dana farber when i was a postdoc we just
finished
a few experiments uh in my lab in the
paper that was recently published at
cancer technology research
and i also want to thank uh people who
are helping me here at
mount sinai the precision monology
institute many collaborators
also collaborators from australia and my
lab is fairly new here in new york
and we are currently recruiting we have
an open position for a postdoc
so if any of you is interested you could
uh let me know you can
write christina or write me directly and
perhaps
we can talk about it thank you very much
good morning everyone uh thank you uh
doctor andrade for
your presentation on your work
very great work about and
leads into the collaboration that we
have done just a little background
of the work that we're presenting today
this is a collaboration that uh
dr daniel grande and i worked
when we were trying to develop a new
method to use image cytometry
to detect nk cell mediated cytotoxicity
so one of the main point was we wanted
to
study the cytotoxicity over extended
period of time
so we went on and used
an image cytometry system to develop a
method to do that
so just a quick presentation outline for
you guys
first we're going to look at the
traditional methods for in vitro
nk cell mediated cytotoxicity assay
uh we're going to look at the
image-based method that we have
developed
to do the co-culture cytotoxicity assay
and we validate that in comparison to a
traditional chromium 51 release assay
and then we looked at long term time
course monitoring of the nk cell killing
over 76 hours
and then finally summary and takeaway
so as we know uh if you are doing
cytotoxicity the traditional method is
to use
a radio active method using the
chromium 51. so first the target cells
are labeled with chromium 51
and they're incubated with target cells
they're spinning washed
and the effector cells are added to the
target cells
then we measure the amount of acromion
that's released in the supernatant to
determine the amount of cytotoxicity
so this could also be it's the same
thing for ldh
and calcium release so this is all part
of the release
acid so
it's specifically the chromium release
act has several issues first
it is hazardous um it does a
endpoint measurement with a short time
window of four hours
typically um it's indirect measurement
by supernatant and this
is common for all the release assays
and requires a significant amount of
cells
typically from what we have experienced
is about 100 000 target cells per well
and that leads to about a million
effector cells
with a 10 to 1 ett ratio
so by using image cytometry assay
we're able to capture images of the co
culture
and count the live target cells over
time so in this case this is a
brightfield images captured by this
legal immune cytometer
and these live target cells are either
stained
or it could be producing fluorescent
proteins
so we can measure the and count the live
target cells
so this is a counted image
then by doing this in a time course
fashion we can measure kinetic
measurement
of cytotoxicity over time so we can use
something like calcium am
tracer dyes or fluorescent proteins to
track the live
target cells and we directly count the
target housing whole well
and this allows us to do a time course
measurement
and using this we can use approximately
10 times less cell so
the lowest we have used is about 1 000
target cells in a well in a 96 well
and that's about uh so commonly we have
seen five thousand to ten thousand
target cells per well
and that leads to about fifty thousand
to one hundred thousand infector cells
with a ten to one 10 to 1 e to t ratio
so in this work uh dr diarande we ran
several plates looking at different
treatment with the antibodies that they
have developed
so we set up an nk cell mediated killing
assay
with a 10 to one to one to one ett ratio
with primary nk cells and also a375
melamo
that's expressing the extreme
fluorescent proteins
so on the right side of the picture
you'll see a
layout of the play map so we have used
a presence or absence of
il2 that can stimulate the nk cells
and also the present absence of the
mecca a mega b antibody
that dr d andrade spoke of
during his presentation and we also have
set up control wells where it's just the
tumor cells only
and we image and analyze this 96 wall
plate up to 76 hours
so with the image cytometry detection
method first we
will collect the zx screen expressing
target cells a375 target cells
and culture in the presence of the
antibodies that that we described
earlier
we see this cell in 96 while plate at
5000
cells per well
then the nk cells are added at varying e
to t
ratios and that's pre-treated with or
without il2
then co-culture the cells for 76 hours
and image and count live target cells
over time
so when we do the image and analysis of
the inherent
a375dx screen positive cells we can see
the fluorescence
and we can count directly count the hair
cells are in this illegal
immune cytometer so the goal is
as the live target cells die
these fluorescent proteins will leak out
of the cells very similar to the release
acne
however in the images we will not see
the cells anymore
doing a cell based analysis so we will
not count those cells
so the only cells we will count will be
the live target cells
that will have the zeal screen positive
signal
so this is a whole plate image that was
captured
by this illegal injury cytometer and
we can see at 76 hours
this is what the image look show shows
you
so when you have the control on the
bottom with the only the
a375 cells or the a375 cells with
anybody
you can see the covering of the zx
screen positive cells in the whole well
then as you go upward you'll see one to
one two to one
five to one and ten to one eqt ratio and
you can see as the e to the ratio
increases the amount of target cells
remaining in the wells decrease also
there's a difference between
if if you there's il-2 or without il2
and with with il2 it shows there's uh
less cells
at a lower entity ratio but the most
dramatic
image is on the right side where you can
see
with the meca a makeup b antibodies
it almost completely eradicate the tumor
cells in the well
so so we can see that high ept ratio
the mega megabits show very effective
killing
so here's a zoomed in image into the
well
so you can see the whole well uh in the
in the picture on the right
and at different ect ratio you can see
that there's a different amount of
killing
and the addition of the antibodies
showed
high cytotoxicity here's another is even
more
zoomed in image that shows uh less cells
on the surface
and these cells could be counted uh
directly in the
in the image cytometry method
and there is noticeable difference
between il2 or without il2
so when we first try to validate this
method we only could compare
the fourth four hour time point to the
chromium 51 release asset at four hour
time point
so it does show a comparable trend we do
notice a small difference at a in the
middle
or in a little bit higher the five to
one e to t ratio
it could be due to the way that the
cells are counted versus
supernate indirect measurement of the
supernatant
so we also captured the data
and the images in a time course study so
we can see at zero hour
if you the one on the top is a375 only
cells
and on the bottom we have the il-2 plus
the isotype
antibody and then the il-2 plus the
antibody the 7c6
and at 6 hours we can see there's no
small difference on the top on the
bottom you can already see some cells
are dying
24 hours many of the zs3 positive cells
are disappearing
at 51 hours the tumor cell only grew
tremendously and the ones with il2
do show some inhibition
and at 76 hours the 7c6
antibody completely eradicated the tumor
cells
while the il2 only
inhibited cell growth and this is at a
5 to 1 etc ratio and we do show
proliferation over time of the controls
wealth
with il2 there's some growth inhibition
but it doesn't eradicate the cells from
the nk cells
and with the again with the antibody
completely eradicated the
a375 tumor cells
so we were able to plot this over time
so in the presence of il2
and mica a makeup b antibody we can show
increase in phytotoxicity
so with the isotype control and the
antibody on the top
it doesn't show any uh
decrease in cell count
due to the the fact that there's no nk
cells there
so without il2 we do see that
the isotype control
are affected at higher
e to t ratio and but with the antibody
it does get affected um at a
lower att ratio you can see the number
of
via screen target cells uh are lower
um at a higher entity ratio
then with il2 that's very significant
where you can see
all the cytotoxicity or the increase
or decrease in the number of zx screen
cells
do show at the earlier ett ratio or at a
lower hd ratio
so nk cells can induce the cytotoxicity
at
higher ett ratio with or with a high l2
and lower att and crystals did not
completely eradicate the a375 cells
so we were able to see them we were able
to see them regrow
regrow back to the
to the higher number
so in the summary and take away this
legal image cytometer was able to
acquire brazil and fluorescent images
over
76 hours the live zs green
a375 cells were directly counted
to determine the cytotoxicity of the
treatment
and the addition of il2 and the mikhail
amicab antibodies significantly improve
the nk cell mediated cytotoxicity
and lower entity ratio by higher 83
co nk cells seem to kill due to
non-specific
interactions at lower att
the nk cells did not completely
eradicate the tumor cells which allow
them to grow back
so if we look at the two different
methods the chromatin release
or other type of release assays
have certain limitations that we try to
overcome
versus if we use uh image space to
directly
count the cells in the wells you can use
different type of tracer dyes
fluorescent proteins to directly count
the cells that can give you
a better cytotoxicity measurement as
well as using lower number of cells and
be able to measure kinetically
so most of the release athletes their
only endpoint
and so if you're using flow cytometry
or luminescence assay typically they are
done as an endpoint as well
if you want to do a time course it is
more difficult you need to set up
multiple plates
to sacrifice itself at different time
points
but with that you kind of disrupt the
natural progress of the cells
so you're not looking at just one plate
and tracking them over time
so the advantage of using an image-based
method
is to be able to track the cells without
trypsinizing them or disrupting them
over time
and see how they behave in a cold
culture
so i would like to acknowledge uh dr
kai wuhilfenik who is the department
chair
of athena farber for the immuno cancer
immunology and virology
and as well as dr lucas de andrade for
the collaboration with us
and we have published this work in the
journal of neurological methods
thank you very much for your attention
and if you have any questions please
type into the question
boxes and doctors then andre and us
will be happy to answer them
thank you dr chan and thank you dr
ferrari de andrade for your informative
presentation
now as dr chan mentioned it's now time
to start our live q a portion of the
webinar
so to our audience if you have any
questions you'd like to ask
please do so now just click on the ask a
question box
located on the far left of your screen
and we will answer as many of your
questions
as we have time for okay let's get
started we have some great questions
coming in
dr ferrari de andrade let's start with
you
how healthy are the animals treated
with anti-shedding antibodies only
so uh i think this is a very good
question because uh
you are basically asking about the
safety profile of this antibody
so unfortunately uh i mean the questions
to your answer is they are extremely
healthy
uh but that's because mice do not have
the mca
or mkb genes and therefore our
antibodies
uh do not bind to to any healthy tissue
on the other hand in humans uh mca mcb
is expressed in the small bowel mucosa
uh therefore there is mechanical
expression in the gut
so it is possible that if it is
antibodies that administrated to
uh to health uh humans uh the antibody
could potentially cause some immuno
reaction in the gut
so we don't know if that is indeed the
case because we did not test
this but in order to really ensure that
this type of antibodies safe
we needed to generate new uh mouse
strains that endogenously expressed mca
very good thank you dr ferrari d'andrade
and
you know let's let's stick with you
let's try this question
did you try to deplete also the cd8a
and if not why so
uh we do deplete acetate t cells uh we
showed in one of our slides
and we saw that the depletion of any key
cells are so of cd8 t cells uh
we saw that the antibodies still work
even in the absence of cd8 t
cells the reason why we did that is
because uh nkg2d
is present not only on k cells but also
on cd8 t
cells and it provides stimulatory
signals to the tcr
however we did not see a a major impact
of cdh t cell depletion
but this could also be because the b16
melanoma cell line is able to escape
t-cell recognition so we may need to
switch to another tumor model such as
mc38 or one in which uh
cdt cell depletion is known to cause an
impact on the tumor bird
you dr chan let's come over to you
could you elaborate on counting more how
do you do counting using the
image so that's a very good
very good question uh in terms of image
cytometry so
um to describe it
what the image cytometer does is it
takes images of the whole well
and uh at about one micron per pixel
and then we'll be able to see the cells
in the well and the software on the on
the image science
will be able to count them directly
using image analysis algorithm
and segment them into individual objects
so
so what we can do is use a fluorescent
image from the zx
green uh channel or the green
fluorescence channel
and count individual cells it is a
little more difficult
with a heron cells like the a375
you have to set up a very stringent
parameter to be able to kill them more
accurately so one other thing to be
careful is you want to make sure
when you do an acid like this using
image cytometers you want to have
uniform seating density
so and you have to choose a time point
and the seating density so that
at the end of the assay you're not
over confluence okay one other way to
prevent this
is to obtain tumor cells or have your
own tumor cells that
expresses a nuclear fluorescent protein
that makes the counting much
much more easy so because you can just
count the nucleus and they behave the
same way as
as they die they lose a fluorescent
signal so we can
count them directly in the images
thank you dr chan now this next question
is also for you
one question here is is there a limit in
time for detection of fluorescence
in image cytometry are time-lapse data
measurable
and for how long
so this is also a very good question so
i think in the
in the paper we do demonstrate a time
lapse data so we're able to
uh show how many cells are counted or
how many live cells remain in the wells
over time over the 76 hours at each time
point that
is captured to enter the limit in time
for the
detection if you have a pretty stable
cell line for target cells
it's pretty good you can go up to until
your
wells are filled with cells or over
consolidate but that's not what we want
to do
so you could see less cells
so you can go for a longer period of
time one other thing is
that's for fluorescent protein
expressing target cells
so you can go a longer period of time
however if you
use something like calcium am usually
that's less than 24 hours and also
depends on the target cells that you're
using
because they do uh spontaneous release
the calcium am so you need to check your
particular target cells to see how fast
they release
or you will lose the signal the second
thing is if you use
a tracer die the tracers that the tracer
dies
if you stain them with the target cell
it doesn't necessarily release them
it actually is very sticky because it
binds on the inside and the outside of
the cell
so at the at the end of the acid if
you're using tracer diet you must use
a viability dye to identify the dead
cells
so currently there it is very difficult
to
do this experiment with primary tumor
cells
because it's not you you can't stain
with a tracer dye
it's actually very messy and you cannot
have it express a certain fluorescent
protein so it is more difficult to do a
primary tumor cell
thank you dr chan now dr ferrari
d'andrade
let's come over to you and this next
question is two parts
have you tested your anti-mcb
antibody in other tumor models less
nk cell dependent and can you see
improvement of tumor control
with nk cells being boosted with the ab
so we have tested our antibodies
in five different tumor models
so uh one is the b16f10 which is uh
indeed in a k-cell dependent
and uh the other two in syngenic uh
synthetic tumor models were the ct-26
which is a colon cancer and also the
llc1
cell line which is a lung cancer cell
line so we
indeed saw an efficacy of the antibody
in all these tumor models
these were data that we actually
published already
and we also did with the two human
melanoma metastasis model
so uh this question is also very
important because uh
uh the way i see this antibody is that
uh i don't think it would work in every
single type of cancer
but if the tumor cells express mickey or
mickey b
uh in my opinion it doesn't matter if it
is a lung cancer
or a melanoma cancer the antibodies
should inhibit mick and it can be
shedding
and at some extent to promote the
antitumor immunity
so now this would be stronger to certain
tumors uh
and weaker to other types of tumors
but but i think this type of antibody
could be broadly you you utilize it
for cancer
thank you have another question for you
let's go with here um
which technique was used to assess s
makes on
the supernatant of cell cultures
so that was done by eliza so it's a
sandwich elisa
and uh so uh i i don't know if i
should say that the manufacturer here
but if the
eliza uses the eliza kit uses an
antibody that's coated to
a well of the elisa plate then we add
the supernatant so
this antibody will capture the mccain
the supernatant
and then we use a detection antibody
that's biotinylated
and then it binds to a different epitope
of the mickey molecule
but this this question is also important
because we showed that our antibody
decreases the signal of soluble mickey
into the supernatants
so one important question is uh do do
our antibodies
compete with the antibodies from the
elisa kit
to bind to mk8 because if they complete
if they compete against
each other it's possible that uh this
loss of signal is
caused not only by inhibition of michel
but also due to
a competition to epitopic binding so we
did this essay
it's a supplementary figure in our paper
and we did indeed we did not
detect a competition between our
antibodies and the antibodies from the
elisa kit
so it seems that uh three different
antibodies are able to bind to the same
a solubomic a molecule so yeah we did
that
by a sandwich eliza
thank you now we have time for a few
more questions but i do want to remind
our audience that
those questions we are unable to answer
live today
and any question that comes in during
our on-demand period
they will be answered by our speakers
via the email address you provide
at the time of registration okay dr chan
let's have you answer this question
why are you doing a 76-hour time course
and not shorter
so the reason why we're doing a long
term
or extended time for the killing assay
is because
there's other interaction that we're
trying to discover
typically this assay is done within a
four-hour time point
and there may be other the initial
hypothesis is that there may be
other uh killing or uh
self-proliferation that we're not seeing
beyond um the four-hour time point
because typically if you
have it's nk cells in your body and
they're interacting with the tumor cells
they're gonna not going to only do it
for four hours and stop
so we want to extend that time to see
what happens later on
one other thing is in the recent years
more people have been trying it from the
immuno-oncology side that we have
worked with have been trying to do a
co-culture
cytotoxicity with low ett ratio
and longer longer killing time points
to more mimic the physiological
relevance of the
of the cytotoxicity so
we wanted to see if we can develop the
longer period of time
of the method or the assay to be able to
see if we can
observe and measure the killing
thank you dr chan dr ferrari de andrade
to what extent does the viability of nk
cells restrict
long-term imaging so this is a very good
question because we know that in a case
cells
require a constant uh signaling via
interleukin-2 or interleukin-15
cytokines and without them in case i
would
die in culture in just a couple of hours
so this is why when leo and i were doing
that a long term
in the case of killing i say we compared
any k cells
with or without io2 so uh
i just wanted to add that for you to do
that in a case of killing essay
it only makes sense if you add a
cytokine
that will enable any key cells to
survive long term
because if you don't do that then any
key cells will be functional just for a
few hours
so therefore the any case of viability
in culture is
essential for you to perform any k cell
mediated the kidney i say
in long terms therefore you need io2 and
you need
interleukin-15 because without them the
nk cells will simply die
thank you and dr chan let's come back
over to you
if file 2 edition induced proliferation
of cells
does it doesn't it change the e to t
ratio
and do you get different results if il2
treated cells
the effectors used instead adding il2 in
the alpha
so i just want to clarify i i think in
in the
in the assay um dr diaz correct me if
i'm wrong
the the nk cells that we use the primary
enkei cells were
pre-treated with the il-2 or without the
il-2 before we
conducted the uh experiment is that
correct
uh yes yes they so the any case the
cases were isolated from healthy donors
but if you do an essay with freshly
isolated indications without any type of
pre-activation
it is extremely unlikely they will be
able to to have any function in vitro
so you always needed to do actually in
my lab we do at least a 24 hours
activation with the io2
before we do any asset
thank you thank you
and dr chan do you have a
co-cultural model protocol regarding any
cell type with nk cells
does the cell counter have capacities to
count both types of cells
that's a very very good question um so
we do have a general protocol
for doing nk cell mediated cytotoxicity
or nk cell
adcc acid or co
they're very similar with different
immune or target cells
so i think the important part is the
second question is does the cell counter
capacity to count both type of cells you
can
but it does take a little bit of setting
up so for example
for the target cells if they have the
fluorescence so we can directly
count them in uh in the images
i have done it multiple ways where
someone would have the infector cells
also expressing fluorescent proteins
in another color that could be picked up
by the image cytometer so
a blue emission or red emission that
could be picked up so we can count it
that way
another thing is we have done car t or t
cell mediated cytotoxicity
and they're very similar to the nk cell
but if you do it
at a high or
medium e to t ratio or even a low ect
ratio
the car t or the t cells or these immune
cells they actually have a
very bright center in the brachial image
so we were able to only pick out
the small bright center cells in the
brighter images so we can
we could trace them or measure
quote-unquote proliferation during the
co-culture incubation time so you could
do it
either by fluorescence or brightview but
if your cells are over confluent and
there's too many cells then it's going
to be very difficult to do that
thank you dr chan and we have time for
one final question
and dr ferrari de andrade let's go with
this final question
do you know within regular cell cultures
like a 549
heck 293 or carcinoma colon rectal cells
such as hct-116 or hd26 cells
the mcbeam uh meek they meet i think the
shedding occurs during their normal
growth in culture
uh i know for for two of these cell
lines
so we tested our antibody in cultures of
a549
and also hct-116 cell lines and indeed
these two cell lines express mca they
proteolytically cleave this protein
it's released in the supernatant and if
we give our antibody to them
uh the antibody inhibits the shedding
and stabilizes the protein
on the cell surface so yeah it is
correct for a549 and adct-1160 lens for
the other two hex 293 or
h t26 we did not test them
very good thank you so much both of you
for this excellent q a
session do either of you have any final
comments for our audience
i just wanna uh this is dr leo chan i
just wanted to thank everyone for
joining our webinar today um and uh
and uh i do wanna wish everyone to be
safe in this uh
current situation and uh definitely
be careful and and
be safe thank you
hello and this is lucas i want to thank
everybody for joining our seminar our
webinar also want to thank uh leo and
christina for
organizing this it's actually very good
to present this type of
webinar in order to distract us a little
bit from this current of our situation
so it was very
useful thank you very much
and thank you both dr lucas ferris
andrade and dr leo chan
for your time today and for your
important research
i'd also like to thank labyrinth and our
sponsor nexalon bioscience for
underwriting today's
educational webcast today's presentation
is
educational and offers continuing
education credits
if you are interested in receiving your
credits please click on the continuing
education credits tab
located at the top right of your
presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credits
this webcast can be viewed on demand and
you may continue to submit questions
during that on-demand period lab routes
will alert you via email when it is
available for replay
and we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
that's all for now and we hope to see
you again soon
stay healthy and have a great day
you